no jaywalking on my watch an illegal
trade that can be more profitable than
drug dealing federal agents have been
fighting cigarette smuggling by
smuggling cigarettes agents buy
truckloads of smokes and low tax states
like Virginia and sell them in high tax
states like New York strawberry nights
the sting operations are designed to
build cases against cigarette smugglers
but ATF cashes in - hmm
robber and tobacco like peanut butter
and jelly federal law allows the agency
to keep booty to cover operational
expenses further blurring the line
between lawbreakers and law enforcers
and agents are apparently pretty sloppy
when handling money in smokes
according to an inspector general report
ATF allowed a confidential informant to
pocket four point nine million dollars
in profits made during just one
operation we need a receipt novel good
the report says over the course of
dozens of stings ATF mishandled 162
million dollars in profits and lost 420
million cigarettes and one scene about
420 million cigarettes and yeah that's
the same ATF that lost thousands of
weapons that ended up in the hands of
Mexican drug cartels and what see my gun
but come on don't cops and federal
agents have better things to do check
out the 80s most one of us that has guys
wanted for attempted murder and actual
murder do you realize you are smuggling
cigarettes so maybe the agency should
spend more time tracking down violent
criminals instead of busting guys who
sell cigarettes the work on a criminal
followed the show on Twitter submit your
nominees for next month and check out
Lauren bouton this month's featured
follower